[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
الرئيس الصيني يزور موسكو لدعم جهود
الوساطه مع كييف واشنطن تستبق برفض اي
دعوه لوقف النار
بريطانيا تحشد لمراهقه بوتين جنائيا
والامن القومي الروسي يحذر من العواقب
المروعه
السودان يتفقون على تشكيل حكومه
الانتقاليه والبرهان يحذر من محاوله خلق
بدائل للجيش
في خامس تجربه صاروخيه خلال الشهر الجاري
تقول انها تحاكي هجوم نوويا على سول
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا يصل في وقت لاحق اليوم
الرئيس الصيني العاصمه الروسيه موسكو في
اول زياره من نوعها منذ اربعه اعوام حيث
يلتقي الرئيس الروسي
بدء الزياره لدى بوتين بما اسمائها سياسه
امريكا لاحتوائها والصين مشيرا الى انها
تاخذ طابعا حادا غير مسبوق وفي مقاله في
صحيفتي الشعب الصينيه
الروسيه اشاد بوتين باستعداد الصين
للاطلاع بدور بناء على صعيد التسويه في
اوكرانيا ورجح رئيس الروسي ان حجم التبادل
التجاري مع بكين هذا العام قد يتجاوز 200
مليار دولار وشددا على ضروره زياده
التبادل التجاري مع الصين بالعملات
الوطنيه بوتين اضاف في المقال ان العلاقات
بين موسكو في قمتها وسيتم مواصله تعزيزها
بدوره قال رئيس الصيني
بشان كيفيه التوصل الى تسويه يعكس وجهات
نظر عالميه ويسهم ايضا في تفاديع ع واقب
الازمه لكنه اقر بان الحلول قد لا تكون
سهله وفي مقال نشره في مستهل زيارته اضاف
الرئيس الصيني انه لا يوجد نظام عالمي
تكون فيه الكلمه الفصل لدوله واحده
افاد صاحبه واشنطن بورس ان زياره الرئيس
الصيني الى روسيا ستوفر دفعه معنويه
عملاقه لرئيس الروسي كما انها فرصه لترسيخ
فكره النظام العالمي لامريكا والذي بشر به
بوتين على حد وصف الصحيفه وفقا للمقال
الذي كتبته مديره مكتب موسكو في بوتين فان
بوتين عفوا يبدو متطلعا الى الدعم الصيني
بشده استعداد لمواجهه عالميه اما بالنسبه
للصين فكما ترى الصحيفه فان توقعات
المسؤولين الصينيين القاتله هي انهم
يدخلون وبشكل واضح عصر المواجهه مع
الولايات المتحده
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي بالبيت
الابيض جون كيربي استبق في حديث لقناه
فوكس نيوز ساندي استبق القمه الروسيه
الصينيه بالقول ان الولايات المتحده سترفض
اي دعوه لوقف اطلاق النار في اوكرانيا
تخرج من اجتماع الرئيسيين الروسي والصيني
في موسكو
اذا خرج من هذا الاجتماع نوع من الدعوه
لوقف اطلاق النار حسنا سيكون هذا غير
مقبول لان كل ما سيفعلهم هو التصديق على
غزو روسيا حتى الان كل ما سيفعله هو اعطاء
السيد بوتين مزيدا من الوقت لاعاده
التاهيل واعاده التدريب والبقاء ومحاوله
التخطيط لهجمات متجدده في الوقت الذي
يختاره نامل وقد قلنا هذا من قبل انا
السيد الرئيس شي سوف يتصل ويتحدث مع رئيس
زيلينسكي ونعتقد ان الصينيين بحاجه للحصول
على المنظور الاوكراني
واضاف كاري بان روسيا والصين غاضبتان من
نظام الدولي الحالي وتريدان صغيره
فشل ليس هناك شك في ان كل من الصين وروسيا
دوله لتنزعجان من هذا النظام الدولي
القائم على القواعد التي انشاتها الولايات
المتحده والعديد من حلفائنا وشركائنا منذ
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه انهم لا
يحبون ذلك انهم يرغبون في اعاده كتابه
قواعد اللعبه على مستوى العالم وقد زادوا
من تعاونهم وعلاقتهم بالتاكيد في الاونه
الاخيره
مشاهدينا ينضموا الينا مراسل عربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد اهلا بك يا عبد الجواد وكيف
تبدو استعدادات موسكو لاستقبال الرئيس
الصيني وما ابرز اجندات الزياره وجدول
اعمالها ايضا
مرحبا احمد صباح الخير نعم بالفعل عند عند
الساعه الواحده والثلاثين دقيقه بالتوقيت
المحلي يصل تصل طائره الرئيس الصيني الى
مطار
الدولي جنوب العاصمه موسكو نعم هي
استعدادات كبيره قد يحدث منها لقاء متوقع
بين الزعيمين الروسي والصيني اليوم في
الكرمن هذا اللقاء قد يكون بعض الساعه
الثالثه بالتوقيت المحلي طبعا اجنده
الحوار هي كبيره على طاوله الحديث بين
الرئيسين احمد ابرزها يكمن في العلاقات
الثنائيه بين البلدين في التعاون في
مناقشه القضايا الدوليه في الوضع الراهن
الازمه الاوكرانيه ستكون حاضره حسب
القراءات السياسيه في البلاد طبعا احمد
هذه الزياره كان قد تم الاعداد لها طويلا
يعني منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر تاتي بدعوه
من الرئيس الروسي لنظيره الصيني تهدف منها
موسكو طبعا وتريد ايصال رساله رغم عدم
الافصاح رسميا عن ولاده قطب جديد لكنها
تبحث من خلال هذه الزياره على التاكيد
بانها تقف مع الجانب الصيني نحو عالم
متعدد الاقطاب يعني يخرج منه الواقع بشيء
قد يؤثر على الساحه الدوليه احمد لابد من
لفت الانتباه بان الصين كانت قد اتخذت
دوما موقفا محيدا بما يخص الازمه
الاوكرانيه تبحث دوما عن حلول للجلوس
لطاوله المفاوضات بين جميع الاضرار
الاطراف تبحث عن حل سلمى قد يعني يصل
بالازمه الاوكرانيه الى نقطه النهايه ولو
على اقل تقدير على قراءه بعض المحللين بان
هذه النقطه لن تكون اخيره لكن قد تكون
لعده سنوات لذلك احنا طبعا موسكو تعول
بشكل كبير على هذه الزياره لقاءات متوقعه
وهي طويله ستكون اليوم بين الرئيسين
الصيني والروسى يوم غد سيلتقي الرئيس
الصيني مع رئيس الحكومه الروسيه ايضا ومن
ثم له لقاء اخر مع الرئيس لابد من الذكر
بان هذه الزياره تمتد حتى الثاني والعشرين
من الشهر الجاري احمد طيب كيف يمكن توصيف
الموقف الروسي عبد الجواد او مدى توافق
بين موسكو وبكين فيما اشرت اليه حول مساله
تشكيل قطب عالمي جديد ايضا مساله السلام
في اوكرانيا
احمد يعني موسكو وبكين تحدثت مرات عده
خاصه قبل الحديث وقبل الاعلان هذا الرسمي
عن هذه الزياره بان الصين وروسيا لا
ترغبان بعوده العالم الى مرحله الحرب
البارده يركبان طبعا في ماده السياسه
العالميه البحث عن عالم متعدد الاقطاب ليس
ليس توجيها كما ذكره ضد الغرب بالرغم من
ان الكثير من المحللين في البلاد يرون في
هذه الخطوه هي ايجابيه نحو ملاحظه الهرم
لكن طبعا كما ذكرت موسكو وكما ذكرت بكين
بان ايجاد عالم متعدد الخطاب اليوم يحتاجه
الجميع لتكون الحريه السياسيه في جميع دول
العالم متاحه لكافه البلدان خاصه يعني مع
وصول الازمه الاوكرانيه الى وضع يعني صعب
للغايه في ظل الدعم الغربي لنظام كييف في
ظل طبعا قيام موسكو بعمليتها العسكريه
ودعم حلفائها في هذا الموضوع لذلك طبعا
وجود الرئيس الصيني اليوم كان قد تم
الاعداد له بشكل كبير وبشكل مطول للجميع
يعرف بان الصين لا تقدم على خطوه حسب
قراءه السياسيين في البلاد
تفاصيل هذه الزياره هي خط اعتذر منك
من جديد
مشاهدينا متابعي الاسواق الاوروبيه تفتح
على خسائر بعد صفقه
من التفاصيل
اذا اعلن وزير الدوله البريطانيه القوات
المسلحه جيمس هيبي عن استعداد لندن لسد
الثغرات في تسليح بولندا والتي ستنتج عن
امداد وارسولكيه بطائرات مقاتله من طراز
مايك 29 وقال لي مجله المانيه ان بريطانيا
تنظر بايجابيه بشان طلب بولندا مل الفجوات
وفعلت هذا وفعلت هذا بالفعل عندما نقلت
وارسو لاول مره دبابات قتاليه رئيسيه من
طراز
الى اوكرانيا واضاف وزير الدوله البريطاني
للقوات المسلحه ان لندن زودت وارسو
بدبابات تشالنجر اثنين بالاضافه الى
المقاتلات مشيرا الى انه حتى الان لم ترد
اي طلبات ذات صله من بولندا مشاهدينا يضع
الاتحاد الاوروبي اللمسات الاخيره على خطه
بقيمه مليارين يورو لتمويل شراء مشترك من
ذخيره المدفعيه التي تحتاجها اوكرانيا
وتجديد مخزونات التداول الدول الاعضاء
وقال مسؤول الاوروبي لوكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه ان الحرب في اوكرانيا دخلت مرحله
خطيره واضاف ان روسيا حشدت اكثر من 300
الف مقاتل تحضيرا لهجوم شامل ومن المقرر
ان يناقش زعماء الاتحاد الاوروبي خلال قمه
يومي الخميس والجمعه اتفاقيه بل اتفاقيه
الشراء المشترك واقرارها
يجتمع وزراء عدل من مختلف دول العالم في
لندن اليوم لمناقشه زياده الدعم بالمحكمه
الجنائيه بعد ان اصدرت مذكره اعتقادنا
الاسبوع الماضي بحق الرئيس الروسي وقالت
الحكومه البريطانيه ان اكثر من 40 دوله
ستمثل فلس ستمثل في المؤتمر الذي تنظمه
المملكه المتحده وهولندا بشكل مشترك واعلن
وزير العدل البريطاني في بيان ان هذا
المؤتمر يدافع عن قضيه تتمثل بمحاسبه
مجرمي الحربي على الفضائع المرتكبه في
اوكرانيا ومن جانبها شددت نظيرته
الهولنديه
على ان الاوكرانيين يستحقون كافه الدعم
لتحقيق العداله
في المقابل انتقد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الروسيديف قرار الجنائي الدوليه
باصدار مذكره اعتقال ضد الرئيس بوتين وقال
في بيان ان قرار الجنائي الدوليه يعني
انهيار مبادئ القانون الدولي وستكون له
عواقب مروعه واتهم المحكمه الجنائيه
بالخضوع الكامل للغرب وانها تعمل وفقا
لتوجيهاته ووصفها بذات السمعه المتدنيه
بحسب تعبيره
بعد ان اصدرت مذكره توقيف بحق بوتين كيف
يمكن اذا للمحكمه الجنائيه ان تطبق قرارها
بحق الرئيس الروسي لاسيما انها بلا جيش
ولا قوه عسكريه نتابعه
من سيقبض على بوتين وكيف بعدما اصبح
مطلوبا للعداله الدوليه بدعوى ارتكابه
جرائم حرب وبامر من المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه
المحكمه ذات الولايات القضائيه العالميه
تختص بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن جرائم الحرب
والاباده الجماعيه عندما لا تستطيع
السلطات الوطنيه القيام بذلك وهذا في
الدول 123 التي وقعت على معاهده انشائها
روسيا ليست واحده منها ليس للمحكمه شرطه
او قوات عسكريه
وتعتمد على السلطات المدنيه في اعتقال
وتسليم المطلوبين قرارات المحكمه تواجه
اشكاليه تتمثل في رفض الدول تسليم
المتهمين
اشكاليه واجهتها في تسليم الرئيس السوداني
السابق عمر البشير اذ رفضت عده دول موقعه
على ميثاق المحكمه
التعاون في اعتقاله بما في ذلك تشاد
وكينيا ويعتبر الرئيس الروسي ثاني رئيس
تصدر بحقه مذكره اعتقال وهو على راس عمله
بعد البشير
واقتصرت بقيه المذكرات على قاده عسكريين
ومسؤولين ارتكبوا جرائم حرب في الحاله
الروسيه يمكن اعتقال بوتين في حالات
محدوده كان يغادر بلده الى دوله قد ترغب
بتقديمه للمحاكمه او ان تسلمه سلطات بلاده
وفي بلد يتمتع بوتين فيه بسلطه مطلقه فانه
من غير المتوقع ان يسعى الكرملين الى
تقديمه للمحكمه الدوليه
المذكره لا معنى لها يقول الكرملين بينما
ينظر اليها الغرب كاشاره من المجتمع
الدولي الى ان ما يحدث في اوكرانيا مخالف
للقانون
وبين هذا وذاك لا احد يستطيع القبض على
بوتين
ونعود مره اخرى مشاهدينا الى موسكو
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد عبد الجواد
الرئيس بوتين لم يعبر حتى الان او يصرح
بشان ما صدر من المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
بمذكره اعتقال بحقه لكن كيف يتفاعل هذا
الملف داخليا في روسيا وهل من مؤشرات على
ان يؤثر سلبا على تحركات الرئيس الخارجيه
احمر يعني في الحقيقه هذا الملف يعني خلال
اليومين الاخيرين يحظى بمناقشه كبيره على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي من جهه ويتصدر
طبعا التصريحات الرسميه ان كانت لمجلس
الامن الروسي على لسان نائب المجلس
والرئيس السابق او الكريم على لسانوف او
الخارجيه او جهات اخرى او مجلس الاتحاد او
الدومه معظمهم طبعا يتحدث عن هذا القرار
يرون فيه هراء كبيرا يعني اخر التصريحات
المثيره للجدل كانت على لسان مدريديف الذي
تحدث على تيليجرام وذكر بان العالم على
الارض هم تحت رحمه الله ورحمه الصواريخ
يعني يقصد بهذا الشيء مهما محكمه لذلك
طبعا الحديث عن محاوله يعني تنفيذ هذا
القرار واعتقال الرئيس بوتين في احد دول
العالم يعني ترى فيه موسكو فرصه
الابتسامه بعض الشيء يعني عندما تحدثنا
ودارت العربيه في شوارع المدينه وناقشت
السكان حول هذا القرار وحول هذه المذكره
يعني معظمهم كانوا يتحدثون عن ان هذا
الشيء هو هراء كبير من قبل الغرب وهو
تصعيد غير مسبوق يعني حول صراع عدد
الاصابع بين موسكو والغرب الى مرحله وحرب
كسر العظام لذلك طبعا هي قضيه كبيره لا
يمكن طبعا اخفاء قلق موسكو منها خاصه ان
الموضوع يطال يعني سيد الكرملين كما
يلقبونه في البلاد لذلك طبعا حتى هذه
اللحظه ما زالت التصريحات هي تردد فعل على
هذا القرار وعلى هذا الاصدار بينما طبعا
على القاعده الشعبيه الناس تؤكد في
كتاباتها وفي حديثها بان هذه بان هذه
الخطوه هي خطوه من الغباء كما سموها بين
الحسين من قبل الغرب نحو سياسه روسيا شكرا
لك من موسكو كنت معنا مراسل العربيه عبر
جواد الرش تحيه عبد الجواد
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
وصلت تقارير عن احتماليه اعتقال ترامب
السلطه الامريكيه تراقب الوضع ولا ادله
على التحضير لاعمال شغب
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد وسط تقارير عن
احتماليه اعتقال ترامب اكد مراسخ
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي في مقابله ان السلطات
الامريكيه تراقب عن كثب الوضع في البلاد
وشدد كيربي على ان مجلس الامن القومي
يراقب الوضع معربا عن امله في سلميه
احتجاجات انصار ترامب في حال وقوعها مؤكده
ان السلطات الامريكيه لم ترصد بعد اي ادله
على التحضير لاعمل الشغب بسبب احتمال
اعتقال ترامب وكان رئيس الامريكي السابق
دون ترامب الذي ينافس في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه اعلن انه سيتم اعتقاله يوم غد
الثلاثاء مطالبا انصاره بالنزول الى
الشارع للاحتجاج من جانبها اعلنت
السيناتور الديمقراطيه اليزابيثوان لشبكه
اي بي سي نيوز الامريكي عن احتماليه توجيه
الاتهامات للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بزعم التستر على مدفوعات ماليه سريه
للنجمه اباحيه خلال حمله الانتخابيه لعام
2016 وردا على سؤال حول ما كانت قلقه بشان
العنف المحتمل بعد ان دعت رامب انصاره الى
الاحتجاج قالت الى انه لا يوجد اي سبب
يدعو الاحتجاج كما دعت ترامب مشدده انه لا
يوجد احد فوق القانون
اذا كان هناك تحقيق يجب السماح لهذا
التحقيق بالمضي قدما بشكل مناسب اذا حان
الوقت لتقديم لوائح اتهام فسوف يقدمون
لوائح اتهام هذه هي الطريقه التي يعمل بها
نظامنا القانوني لا يوجد سبب للاحتجاج على
هذا هذا هو القانون الذي يعمل كما ينبغي
دون خوف او محاباه لاحد
دعوه واحده من الرئيس الامريكي السابق
ترامب كانت كفيله بان تفتح باب جدل واسع
الرئيس الامريكي السابق اعلن انه يتوقع
القاء القبض عليه الثلاثاء في منهجه خلال
مثوله امام المحكمه وحتى انصاره على
الاحتجاج رغم كونها مجرد توقعات من ترامب
حسب ما اكد المتحدث باسمه فان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق فضل ان يقدم على ضربه
استباقيه بالفعل اتت المرجوه منه
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي السابق جون
بولتن نصح المدعي العام بعدم الاقدام على
اتهام ترامب الا ان كان متاكدا للغايه من
التهم الموجهه له لافتا الى ان براءه
ترامب ستسجل في التاريخ على انها كانت
التهمه التي اكسبته كرسي الرئاسه مجددا
نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق مايك بينس
اعتبر ان توجيه الاتهام المحتمل من مدعي
عام مقاطعه منهات الى الرئيس
مقلق للغايه وستكون محاكمه مشحونه سياسيه
فيما اعتبر الرئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن قاسي ان مدعي عاما هاتا يسيء استخدام
السلطه ويسعى الانتقام سياسي من الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب بينما حث السيناتور
الجمهوري
على المقاومه واخذ القضيه الى المحكمه
العليا اما المدعي العام في منهات فحذر من
عدم التسامح مع محاولات ترامب لترهيب
المحققين واعلن التنسيق مع الشرطه نيويورك
لحمايه المحققين من اي تهديدات لغه ترامب
في مناشده انصاره الوقوف معه ضد اعتقاله
اعادت للاذهان لغته التي استخدمها خلال
تغريدات حركت انصاره في احداث الكابيتال
التي ادت لاعمال شغب واسعه لا تزال
تداعياتها حديث الاوساط السياسيه
الامريكيه
الى هذا الخبر العاجل عن تراجع اسهم يو بي
اس بنسبه ثمانيه في المئه فاصله بعد صفقه
الاستحواذ على بنك
السويسريه بالعوده الى سياق نشاطنا
مشاهدينا قال رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقاليه السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
ان الجيش استجاب للشعب بمدنيه الحكم مشددا
على ان المؤسسه العسكريه اصليه وليس لها
بديل ولا توجد قوه تحل محلها في اشاره على
ما يبدو لقوات الدعم السريع واضاف البرهان
ان هناك قوه سياسيه مدنيه تحاول خلق بدائل
للجيش لتمرير اجنده ولن ينجحوا بحسب
تعبيره وتعهد البرهان بترك المجال للقوى
السياسيه الحقيقيه وليست المزيفه او التي
تستعين بالبدائل والخوالف على حد وصفه
وفي تطور جديد في الازمه السودانيه اعلن
المتحدث الرسمي باسم العمليه السياسيه
خالد عمر يوسف اعلن ان الاطراف توافقت على
توقيع الاتفاق النهائي لحل الازمه
السياسيه في البلاد في الاول من ابريل
المقبل
النهائي يوم واحد في ابريل القادم ان شاء
الله
وسيتم التوقيع على الدستور الانتقالي يوم
6 ابريل على ان تبدا تشكيل مؤسسات السلطه
الانتقاليه يوم 11 ابريل
المقبل المواقيت يتفق عليها في اجتماع
النهار اليوم بحضور الفريق
الايطالي والاليات الثلاثيه والعاليه
الرباعيه والاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا تمت
مراجعه ترتيباتك مع السادسه والنصف كامل
المتوقعين وبعض القوه غير المواقع الاتفاق
الاطاري انها تنضم لهذا الاجتماع لكي تشكل
مع بقيه القوى الموقعه على الاتفاق الاطار
العاليه
اللجنه المختصه بالصيانه ولكن
بكل اسف في اللحظه الاخيره اعتقد اصدر بعض
هذه القوه مواقف معلنه بعدم حضور الاجتماع
انعقد
واضاف المتحدث الرسمي باسم العمليه
السياسيه انه تم تشكيل اللجنه التي ستتابع
او اللجنه السياسيه الخاصه بصياغه الاتفاق
النهائي وفق المرجعيات التي تم الاتفاق
عليها
الاليه التي اجتمعت مساء اليوم في القصر
الجمهوري هي ما يعني ما ما جهه جديده من
عليها التنفيذ الاتفاق عندما مهمه فقط
محدده هي اختيار اللجنه
الصياغه لصياغه الاتفاق النهائي ومن ثم
المتابعه مع لجنه الصياغه لضمان ان تفرغ
من عملها وفقا للمواقيت المتفق عليها يعني
ستبدا رياض الصياغه عملها ان شاء الله
ابتداء من اليوم الغد
ومن الخرطوم مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم وما
الذي رشح من معلومات حول ما جرى في الغرف
المغلقه وافضل الى هذا التوافق والتقارب
بين فرقي الازمه السودانيه
مرحبا احمد الهادي وبكل المشاهدين في
البدء
بالامس كان المؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقده خالد
عمر يوسف الناطق الرسمي باسم العمليه
السياسيه النهائيه واتحدث عن مواقيت لهذه
العمليه وهذا هو الجديد بان تحدث هناك
مواقيت بتوقيتات زمنيه وكان الشارع
السوداني قد ابدى امتعاضا من هذه العمليه
السياسيه بانها مفتوحه الامد لا توجد لها
مواقيت ربما جاءت للاجابه على هذا التساؤل
بالامس ردود الافعال تباينت ما بين الرفض
والتاييد لكن الشارع السوداني في غالبه في
هذه الفتره ولكن انشغال كما يرى البعض
انشغال بالاستعداد لشهر رمضان المبارك
وربما الرواج السياسي ليس بالقدر الذي كان
في السابق لكن بكل تاكيد هناك رافضين
وهناك مؤيدين لهذه العمليه السياسيه
المؤيدون معروفون تماما وهم القوى
المتوقعه لاتفاق الايطالي وهناك الرافضون
وهي الكتله الديم الوطنيه كما اسمت نفسها
هي ايضا رافضه لهذا الاتفاق الايطالي وقد
اصدرت بيانا بالامس ترفض فيه هذا الاجتماع
وانها دعيت لهذا الاجتماع لكنها لن تاتي
بهذا الشكل بحسب وصفها طيب يعني بعض القوى
كما تفضلت
سالم ايضا رات في هذا الاتفاق اتفاقا
اقصائيا
بعضها كما تفضلت ايضا رفض حضور هذا
الاجتماع لكن بعض الاخر حضر الاجتماع اليه
الاليه الثلاثيه فكيف يمكن فهم موقف هذه
القوه في ظل هذه التطورات
الان الوضع احمد هو ان هذه القوه بالامس
هي قد دعيت لان القوى الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي او بشكل ادق كل القوى
الموقعه لاتفاق الايطالي قد وجهت دعوه
لهذه القوه لكنها الدعوه لم تاتي للكتله
الديمقراطيه جاءت لاجزاء من هذه الكتله
الديمقراطيه او لكتل منها على سبيل المثال
مني اركب الناوي جبريل ابراهيم تيجاني
السيسي وكذلك جعفر المرغني هذه الكتل
الاربع او هذه القيادات الاربعه بكتلها
دعيت لان تكون ضمن الاتفاق الايطالي بقيه
المكونات الكتله الديمقراطيه لم تدعى
وربما هذه نقطه الخلاف بين الكتله
الديمقراطيه وبين القوى الموقعه لاتفاق
الى
الاتفاق الايطالي ترى ان هذا اغراق
للعمليه السياسيه لكي لا تنجح وهو
القوى الاخرى التي ترفض ترى ان هذا الامر
اقصاء وفيه عدم جديه من الاتفاق القوى
الموقعه الاتفاق الايطالي ليست لها جديه
في المضي قدما في العمليه السياسيه طيب
الخلافات داخل المنظومه العسكريه الى اي
مرحله وصلت
وتوقيع هذا الاتفاق النهائي بعد ايام هل
يعني نهايه هذه الخلافات في هذه المنظومه
العسكري والتي ستكون في غضون يومين فقط من
الخرطوم كنت معنا مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي تحياتي سالم
مشاهدينا قال وزير خارجي العراقي فؤاد
حسين ان وساطه بغداد نجحت في التوصل الى
اتفاق موسم بين ايران والسعوديه هو اعاده
العلاقات بين
البلدينج
العراق قادم مبادره فعاله في المنطقه
بعضها انتهى بنجاح وتوجا باتفاق بين بلدين
نحن سعداء بهذا الاتفاق وعوده العلاقات
بينهما في المنطقه ما يعني خفض التوتر
وتركيز العراق على اعاده بناء اقتصاده
وامنه داخل اراضيه وفي المنطقه
بدوره اكد سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان استئناف العلاقات بين
السعوديه وايران سيسهم في استقرار المنطقه
وذلك خلال مؤتمر جمعه بوزير الخارج
العراقي فؤاد حسين في بروكسل
لقد شاهدنا مؤخرا استئناف العلاقات بين
السعوديه وايران وهذا ما قد يساهم في
استقرار المنطقه ودعونا لا ننسى بان
الجوله الاولى من المفاوضات في بغداد هي
التي ادت لمخرجات ايجابيه
دخل شركه تابعه لنيوركم في اتفاقيه مع
جهات تنظيميه امريكيه لشراء الودائع
والقرون من بنك
والذي تم اغلاقه قبل اسبوع واستشهد الصفقه
توالي الشركه واسمها
الى حد الى حد كبير جميع ودائع
وبعض محافظ قروضه وجميع فروعه السابقه
البالغ عددها 40 وفق المؤسسه الاتحاديه
للتامين الودائع وقالت المؤسسه ان قروض
بنك التي تقترب من 60 مليار دولار ووضائعه
البالغه 44 مليار دولار ستبقى ضمن وصايتها
القضائيه
هذا وانضم مجلس الاحتياطي الاتحادي في
الولايات المتحده الى بنوك كندا وانجلترا
واليابان والبنك المركزي الاوروبي والبنك
الوطني السويسري كذلك انضم اليهم في اجراء
منسخ لتوفير السيوله من خلال ترتيبات خطوط
مبادله الدولار وتشير هذه الخطوه الى شده
قلق محافظ بنوك المركزيه بشان الاضرابات
بل الاضطرابات الاخيره في النظام المالي
في اوروبا والولايات المتحده هذا وقال
البنك المركزي الاوروبي ان انقاذ بنك
السويسري كان ضروريا لاستعاده الهدوء في
الاسواق الماليه وانه لا يزال مستعدا لدعم
بنوك منطقه اليورو بقروض اذا لزم الامر
ورحبت كريستيانو رئيسه البنك في بيان رحبت
بالاجراء السريع والقرارات التي اتخذتها
السلطات السويسيه والتي كانت الضروريه
لاستعاده اوضاع السوق المنتظمه وضمان
الاستقرار المالي واضافت ان القطاع
المصرفي في منطقه اليورو يتمتع بالمرونه
مع وجود مراكز قويه لراس المال والسيوله
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
احتياجات جديده تضرب فرنسا والمعارضه تسعى
لاسقاط الحكومه تحت قبه البرلمان
الرئيس الصيني يزورو موسكو لدعم جهود
الوساطه مع كييفو واشنطن تستبق برفض اي
دعوه لوقف النار
بريطانيا
يتفقون على تشكيل حكومه انتقاليه والبرهان
يحذر من محاوله خلق بدائل للجيش
في خامس تجربه صاروخيه خلال الشهر الجاري
تقول انها تحاكي هجوما نوويا على
مشاهدينا من جديد يصوت البرلمان الفرنسي
اليوم على مذكرتين لحجم الثقه عن الحكومه
الفرنسيه واسقاطها على خلفيه اقرار رئيس
ايمانويل ماكرون لنظام رفع سن التقاعد جاء
ذلك بالتزامن مع استمرار الاحتجاجات في
الشوارع واضرابات عن العمل في قطاعات
متعدده منها الملاحه الجويه حيث دعت هيئه
الطيران المدني الى الغاء 30% من الرحلات
الجويه في مطار اورلي
مشاهدينا من باريس انضم الينا مراسله
العربيه وادي الداهوك اهلا بك فادي بدايه
فادي ما الذي دفع البرلمان الفرنسي للتبني
هذه الخطوه على الرغم ان الخطوه التي قام
بها الرئيس ماكرون باقرار قانون رفع سن
التقاعد دون الرجوع الى البرلمان هي خطوه
دستوريه
اهلا احمد ما دفع قوى المعارضه الى القيام
بهذه الخطوه انهم غير متفقين او غير
راضيين عن مشروع رفع سن التقاعد الى 64
عاما وايضا لان الفرنسيين في معظم
استطلاعات الراي التي اجريت عربوا في 84%
منهم اعربه انهم ضد رفع سن التقاعد الى 64
عاما لذلك كان من اللازم ان يمر هذا
المشروع عبر البرلمان لتصويت النواب لكن
ذلك لم يحصل لان الرئيس فرنسي كان او كان
يعلم ان هذا المشروع لن يمر عبر البرلمان
لن يصوت عليه النواب لذلك لجا الى استخدام
الماده 49.3 وتسبب بهذه الازمه اليوم هناك
حاله من الغليان شعبيا وسياسيا ضد هذا
المشروع على الشارع التظاهرات مستمره في
معظم المدن الفرنسيه وخصوصا في العاصمه
باريس يوم امس كان هناك تظاهرات واعمال
عنف ايضا
حجم الثقه عن الحكومه الفرنسيه من قبل
البرلمان في هذا التوقيت ما الذي يعنيه
على الصعيد المشهد السياسي فرنسا
حجم الثقه عن الحكومه في حال تم التصويت
اليوم سيعني اسقاطها اي على رئيسه الحكومه
اليزابيث ان تقدم استقالتها لكن هذه
المساله ما زالت غير واضحه تماما لان
البرلمان بحاجه الى
287 صوتا من اصل 577 اي يحتاج الى
الغالبيه
ان تسقط الحكومه اذا ما صوت النواب على
المذكرتين ونجحوا باسقاطها على اليزابيث
بون ان تقوم بتقديم استقالتها لكن حتى
الان هذا النصاب غير مكتمل هناك نوع من
الغموض وربما تحدث مفاجات لان هناك عدد من
النواب من حزب الجمهوريين اعلنوا انهم
سيصوتون لصالح هذا المذكرتين علما ان
الحزب الجمهوري هو داعم لهذا المشروع
وايضا هناك
نواب من تحالف الرئيس ايضا اعلنوا انهم
مستعدين لتصويت للتصويت على المذكرتين
الحاله ضبابيه بعض الشيء ما زالت لكن
التصويت صيد يعني هل ينظر سنعرف
تفاصيلات بانها تشكل خطرا على مستقبل
الرئيس السياسي وهل هناك ايضا مؤشرات فادي
على امكانيه تراجع الحكومه عن هذه
القرارات التي اتخذتها
مساله ان يتمكن النواب من اسقاط الحكومه
قد تدفع الرئيس للتفكير بالتراجع عن مشروع
رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما ايضا شعبيه
الرئيس في انخفاض مستمر وايضا هذا قد يشكل
عاملا مهما في هذه المساله يوم امس صدر
استطلاع للراي
وشعبيه الرئيس انخفضت الى ادنى مستوى لها
منذ عام 2018 منذ ازمه السترات الصفر بلغت
28% ايضا هناك استطلاعات صدرت يوم امس
كذلك بخصوص مذكرتي حجم الثقه اعربه 74% من
الفرنسيين رغبتهم بان تسقط الحكومه وبان
يصوت النواب لصالح مذكرتي حجم الثقه
الدعوات ما زالت مستمره لتنظيم احتجاجات
واضرابات في مختلف البلاد رغم الحديث او
التقرير الذي يتحدث عن
انحسارها وخفوت زخم هذه الاحتجاجات ما اخر
هذه الدعوات هذه
هناك دعوات مستمره للتظاهر اليوم قد تخرج
تظاهرات مساء اليوم او بعد جلسه البرلمان
خصوصا في العاصمه باريس هذه الاحتجاجات
بات تخرج من دون تنسيق من دون اعلان مسبق
وهي تخرج بشكل عشوائي وعفوي وخصوصا من قبل
الطلاب الذين هم راس الحربه اليوم في هذه
الاحتجاجات او على الاقل منذ يوم الخميس
الماضي عندما اقر اقرت الحكومه اقرار هذا
القانون عبر المده
49,3 لكن ايضا سيكون يوم الثالث والعشرين
من هذا الشهر يوم الخميس المقبل هو يوم
تعبئه كبير جدا وسيشهد تظاهرات
وايضا اضراب ضخم جدا ستنظمه النقابات
وايضا الاحزاب اليساريه على الاقل الاحزاب
الخمسه اليساريه تدعم هذه التظاهرات سيكون
يوما للتظاهر والاضراب ايضا نعم وسنكون
معك في متابعه لهذا اليوم الطويل في فرنسا
من فيروس كنت معنا مراسل العربيه فادي
الداهوك تحياتي فادي
اكاد رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان في خطاب بثه على موقع يوتيوب
بعد يوم من اشتباك انصاره مع الشرطه في
منزله في لاهور اكد على انه سيتخذ اجراءات
قانونيه ضد الشرطه لاقتحام منزله كما اعلن
خان عن خطط لتنظيم تجمع عام يوم الاربعاء
حيث يواجه خان سلسله من الطعون القانونيه
بما في ذلك التحدي الذي ادى الى محاوله
فاشله لاعتقاله
كان من المفترض ان اتحدث اليكم بالامس لكن
عندما وصلت الى المنزل كان هناك مشهد
للدمار والنهب ولهذا السبب لم استطع
التحدث في الليله الماضيه وكان من الصعب
الجلوس هنا في هذه الغرفه لانني لا اعرف
نوع الغاز المسير للدموع الذي استخدمه
الشرطه لكنه لا يزال يؤذي عيني الان حان
الوقت لقد جمعت جميع محامي اليوم وسنرفع
دعوى ضد كل ضابط شرطه اقتحم منزلي نحن
نرفع قضيه ازدراء في المحكمه العليا في
لاهور بسبب الطريقه التي هاجموا بها منزلي
وفي الناصريه مشاهدينا جنوب العراق اقدم
مسلحان على اغتيال استاذ جامعي قبل يومين
جريمه لقد استنكارا وادانه للمجتمع
العراقي ومواجهه ومواجهه سرعان ما حسبتها
القوات الامنيه بالقاء القبض على المشتبه
بهم بتسليمهم للقضاء العراقي
هذا
هو الناريه وهو على مقربه من منزله ليفارق
الحياه بعد نقله الى المستشفى
مجلس العزاء كسر حزنه التاهب الكبير
للقوات الامنيه والقاء القبض على الجنات
نتقدم بالشكر الجزيل الى قياده الشرطه
والاجهزه الاستخباريه جميعا لجهودها
المبذوله وملاحقه الجينات والقبض عليهم
الاوساط التعليميه مع زميلهم واستنكرت ما
حدث وحولت المصابه الى تظاهرات تطالب
بالقصاص من القتله وانهاء ظاهره السلاح
الممتلد الذي يستهدف كفاءات العراق
ان قتل دوله اثنين القتلوا اخونا بدون سبب
وعمرنا لا شايفينهم ولا هم شايفيننا
ابدا فاحنا نطالبهم بالقصاص الالهي قصاص
اول مره حكم الله وثانيا حكم القانون
القانون العراقي يؤكد هذا الشيء 460 القتل
المتعمد يعني فوضى يعني حتى الحيوانات
عندها بعض الفكر وبعد النظام
القوات الامنيه نجحت في القبض على
المتهمين بجريمه في وقت قصير سرعه تحرك
القوات الحكوميه ابقت على الامن والهدوء
الذي عاشته المحافظه منذ شهور دون ان تشوه
صورته هذه الحادثه لقناتي العربيه والحدث
شاكر عواد الناصريه
كشف تقرير صحيفه
ولكنها تدور في افريقيا حيث تتبع الولايات
المتحده نفس التكتيكات في اوكرانيا لاحباط
توسع النفوذ الروسي واشنطن وان واشنطن
كشفت مخططا لاغتيال رئيس تشادي على يد
مرتزقه فاجنر الروسيه نتابعه
احدى اسخن البقاع على الارض تدور حرب
بارده جديده بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
حرب مدفوعه بالسلاح والذهب وحتى وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لتوسعه النفوذ وما
الفراغ الذي خلفه الفرنسيون في تشاد حضرت
واشنطن الرئيس محمد ادريس ديبي مؤخرا من
ان المرتزق الروس يخططون لقتله مع ثلاثه
من كبار مساعديه وان موسكو تدعم المتمردين
المحتشدين في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
المجاوره
وقت نفسه تغازل موسكو المتعاطفين داخل
النخبه الحاكمه في تشاد بمن فيهم الوزراء
والاخ غير الشقيق للرئيس
وفقا لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز قرار الحكومه
الامريكيه مشاركه معلومات استخباراتيه
حساسه مع رئيس دوله افريقيه ياتيك احد
التكتيكات الجديده التي تتحرك بها اداره
بيض لافشال المكاسب الروسيه في افريقيا
كذلك التحرك الامريكي ياتي استباقا للتمدد
روسيا في المستعمرات الفرنسيه السابقه مثل
مالي وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى بعدما تخللت
عنه حيث تمثل محاوله اغتيال الرئيس وتنصيب
اخيه غير الشقيق فصلا جديدا من جهود قوه
فاجنر لتوسعه النفوذ الروسي سواء بالقتل
او بتراخيص استخراج الماس والذهب
خلال العام الماضي وفيما يشبه التسابق بين
الجانبين كفف مسؤولون امريكيون زياراتهم
الى افريقيا فيما يستعد بايدن لزياره ايضا
هذا العام كان زار 7 دول في القاره خلال
العام الاخير اذ تؤكد واشنطن الساعه يا
موسكو لتثبيت اقدامها هناك بدات تظهر في
اريتريا ايضا وعبر مرتزقه فاجنر اقدام
يريد الكرملين ان يخطو بها بين البحر
الاحمر
والمحيط الاطلسي
يعاني سكان محافظه تعز من ارتفاع اجور
العقارات ولا سيما الشقق السكنيه التي
ارتفعت اسعارها الى اكثر من مئه في المئه
في الاونه الاخيره ونجات عشرات الاسر الى
اخلاء الشقق السكنيه والعيش في دكاكين
صغيره تفتقر للنوافذ والتهويه ولا تصلح
للعيش
قد لا تبدو المدينه هذه المزدحمه بالسكان
قادره على استيعاب المزيد من الناس ولا
سكانها انفسهم قادرين على دفع تكاليف
السكن فالاسر الفقيره هنا وخاصه للنازحه
اتخذت من هذه الدكاكين مسكنا لها بعد رفع
ملاك العقارات اجور الشقق السكنيه في تعز
الى اكثر من مئه في المئه
ادقون على قدر على قدر حالي اما الشقه ما
اقدرش استاجر شقه ابدا نهائيا لان الوضع
ان الايجارات ارتفعوا الاسعار احنا ما
نقدرش
150 150 180 الايجار حق الشقاق نجحنا
ولا حاجه من احنا سبعه بنتي شباب بسبب ان
احنا نقدر نستعجل شقه ليست هذه الاسره
وحدها من اضطرت للعيش في مكان يفتقر
لنافذه واحده بل هناك العشرات من الاسر
واجهه المصير ذاته بعد ارتفاع اجور الشقق
السكنيه الى 150 الف ريال للشهر الواحد
اوضاع سويه صعبه تعيشها هذه الاسر في
اماكن اشبهوا بالسجون مع ترد الوضع
المعيشي وانقطاع الرواتب وتراجع الثرث
العمل في البلد
غير هذا الموتور يعني باريس قلم انه اكلنا
شربنا كسوفه العيد مصاري في رمضان
على حسب الظرف حاولنا جاهدين على ان نقنن
هذه المساله وقلنا يجب ان يرفع
بالجانب المنطقي وهو عشره في المئه الى
20% اما ان يرفع 200 الى 300% فهذا شيء
غير مقبول هكذا اذا بدا مسكن الاسر
الفقيره في المدينه هذه وهكذا بدا حالهم
مع ارتفاع اجور السكن امر دفع بعض الاسر
الى مغادره المدينه التي تفتقر الى اليات
تنظم الاجوره بين المواطن وملاك العقارات
الى اكثر من مئه في المئه اذا ارتفعت اجور
العقارات والشقق السكنيه داخل محافظه تعز
وهو من عكس سلبا على الحياه المعيشيه
للمواطن اليمني لكن الجهات الحكوميه تحاول
جاهده الحد من هذه الاشكاليه هل سعيد
العربيه تعز
في سوريا مشاهدينا اعلنت فراخ الانقاذ
مواصله عمليات البحث عن طفلين مفقودين بعد
ان غامرت مياه النهر الخابور الذي فاض
جراء الامطار لغزيره وتسبب في غرق منازل
بمدينه الحسكه
[موسيقى]
تهدينا هدد زعيم كوريا الشماليه
في اي وقت لمواجهه تهديدات امريكا وكوريا
الجنوبيه على حد قوله ونقلت وكاله انباء
كوريا الشماليه عن اتهامه
في ذلك القدرات النوويه الامريكيه في
السياق اكدت كوريا الشماليه اجراء تدريبات
عسكريه على مدار اليومين الماضيين في
محاكاه لهجوم نووي تكتيكي بما في ذلك
اطلاق صاروخ برستي يحمل رؤوسا نوويا بل
راسا وهميا وكانت تدريبات هدفها ارسال
تحذير قوي للولايات المتحده وكوريا
الشماليه اول جنوبيه عفوا هذا ورفضت
تاجهات علميه في الولايات المتحده تضخما
في حجم الطحالب الحمراء وقد ادت هذه
الكميه الكبيره من الطحالب لنفوق عدد من
الاسماك وتشويه الواجهه البحريه لعده
شواطئ
امواج من الطحالب الحمراء على مد الشواطئ
الامريكيه الغربيه وفي عدد من جزر
الكاريبي ظاهره اثارت الهلع بسبب ضخامتها
فقد بينت صور الاقمار الصناعيه ان المد
الاحمر او ما يسمى علميا
يصل حجمه الى مرتين من مساحه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
منذ عشر سنوات هذه هي المره الاولى التي
نرى هذه الظاهره بهذا الحجم تكاثر الطحالب
ادى الى نفوق عدد من الاسماك وحتى بعض
الحيتان وذلك لان هذا النوع يمتص الاكسجين
الموجوده في المياه فيتسبب في اختناق
الاحياء البحريه ولكن العلماء ما زالوا
غير متاكدين من سبب هذه الموجه
يمكننا علاج هذا الامر اذا حددنا سبب
التكاثر وقد تضاعف حجم موجه الطحالب مرتين
بين ديسمبر ويناير يعتقد العلماء ان
الاحتباس الحراري هو من اسباب تضخم حجم
الطحالب التي بتكاثرها تزيد نسبه الملوثات
في مياه البحر التي قد تتبخر لتسقط مع
الامطار لتؤثر بذلك على المحاصيل الزراعيه
وعلى صحه البشر انس نماسي العربيه
دعا سكان بلده ميليندي الواقعه اقصى غرب
ولايه الاستراليه دعوا السلطات الى التصرف
بسرعه وبدء التنظيف بعد العثور على مئات
الالاف من الاسماك النافقه عائمه في نهر
دارلينك
وفي النهايه نذكر
الرئيس الصيني لدعم جهود الوساطه معك
جنائيا والامن القومي الروسي يحذر من
العواقب المروعه
فرقاء السودان يتفقون على تشكيل حكومه
الانتقاليه والبرهان يحذر من محاوله خلق
بدائل للجيش
في خامس تجربه صاروخيه خلال الشهر تقول
انها تحاكي هجوما نوويا على
امان الله مشاهدينا